tu madame la parole est à monsieur
bernard gérard merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre samedi dernier un jeune
homme de 20 ans de nationalité
éthiopienne est mort écrasé par
plusieurs poids lourds sur l'autoroute
a16 entre calais et dunkerque
chaque jour ce sont actuellement plus de
50 personnes dont de nombreux mineurs
qui affluent à nouveau sur calais ou
grande synthe le retour des migrants
autant prévisible que redoutée semble
être largement amorcé les associations
les hôpitaux le 115 sont d'ores et déjà
débordés monsieur le premier ministre
les mesures que vous aviez prison était
présenté comme un accord gagnant gagnant
or la répartition des 7 à 8000 personnes
dans les centres d'accueil et
d'orientation dont plusieurs spécialisé
pour les mineurs semble ne répondent
nullement aux engagements que vous avez
pris le camp d'accueil de grande synthe
comporte quant à lui plus de 1200
personnes
il n'a jamais été démantelé grande
synthe semble être une vaste plateforme
gérée ni plus ni moins par des
trafiquants sollicitant 15000 euros par
passage en angleterre et représentant un
chiffre d'affaires phénoménal de 600000
euros par mois et par passeur je
souhaiterais que vous nous fassiez un
point sur la gestion de cette crise des
migrants pour les calaisiens d'une part
et pour les émigrés d'autre part
monsieur le premier ministre
combien de personnes ont été reconduites
à la frontière combien de jeunes ont pu
regagner légalement l'angleterre et
rejoindre leurs familles telles que cela
était prévu quelle est l'attitude
actuelle du gouvernement britannique
dans la gestion de cette crise sans
précédent quelles mesures sont prises
pour éviter le retour des migrants à
calais et faire cesser les trafics
scandaleux à grande-synthe
monsieur le premier ministre que faites
vous pour que ce problème soit traité à
la source c'est à dire bien sûr aux
frontières de l'europe mais aussi au
large de la méditerranée
merci la parole et à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur bruno le roux
monsieur le député bernard gérard vous
avez posé de nombreuses questions je
souhaite pouvoir y répondre de la façon
la plus précise qui soit j'étais il y a
encore trois heures dans votre
département
à la préfecture de région pour remettre
à 60 jeunes qui avaient vu leur dossier
instruit le récépissé délivré par
l'ofpra afin qu'ils puissent vous le
savez s'inscrire dans le cadre d'un
dispositif pilote proposé par la
préfecture les universités lave pas dans
un dispositif de vie et donc je parle de
ces 60 parce que concrètement ils sont
l'image de ce qui s'est passé ces
derniers mois sur le camp de calais avec
un démantèlement qui s'est fait dans des
conditions particulièrement remarqué
tant par les habitants que par les
associations qui ont accompagné ce
processus associations avec lesquelles
nous continuons avec madame la ministre
du logement d'entretenir des rapports
réguliers parce que nous n'en avait pas
fini parce que nous n'en avons pas fini
et je voudrais sur quelques points vous
apporter des réponses précises sur les
jeunes d'abord oui il s'agit d'un jeune
de 20 ans et qui était dans un chaos me
vous savez que dans les centres
d'accueil et d'orientation mineurs en
dehors du soutien nous faisons assez
jeunes pour qu'ils puissent déposer les
dossiers puisque leur objectif est
toujours de passer au royaume uni nous
menons un certain nombre de tests pour
vérifier s'ils correspondent bien et
s'ils sont bien mineur à l'évidence ce
jeune qui malheureusement a été heurté
par un camion n'était pas mineur il
venait d'un centre de corrèze une
manifestation a eu lieu et ces jeunes
souhaitaient se mobiliser pour rejoindre
leurs collègues nous les en avons
dissuadés
ils sont restés aujourd'hui en corrèze
et ils ne sont pas à calais je voudrais
adresser un message au gouvernement
britannique
il faut respecter les critères qui ont
été définis le sentiment d'injustice à
ce que les britanniques ne respecte pas
aujourd'hui la parole qu'ils ont donnée
est porteur de graves désillusions
j'espère avoir l'occasion de vous
répondre plus précisément sur les
chiffres que vous me donnez puisque bien
entendu cette question est importante
merci monsieur le ministre intérieur la
parole et canada